oui, j'ai toujours pensé que la peine de mort
était probablement une bonne idée, puis un
jour j'ai changé d'avis.
J'ai été avocat pendant dix ans et
j'étais en faveur de la peine de mort.
la
croyance chrétienne fondamentaliste inconditionnelle selon
laquelle vous savez que c'est un iPhone je que
c'est là que j'ai grandi et j'ai
toujours pensé que la peine de mort était
probablement une bonne idée et puis un jour
j'ai changé d'avis
et j'étais dans le couloir de la mort un jour au
Mississippi  en faisant des recherches sur un livre intitulé
la chambre et je viens de réaliser que tous
ces efforts pour mettre des hommes dans le couloir de la mort,
puis pour les exécuter, étaient tout simplement faux
parce que nous pouvons tous convenir que tuer est
mal, alors pourquoi l'État assume-t-il l'
autorité de pouvoir tuer  ce n'est pas
juste encore une fois, cela revient au racisme, vous
savez, les Noirs sont plus susceptibles d'obtenir
la peine de mort, puis les Blancs
et il y a beaucoup de problèmes avec
cela et donc depuis 25 ans, j'ai
essayé de travailler à nouveau  au lieu de la peine de mort,
ce que j'essaie de faire, c'est de présenter un problème et d'y
faire réfléchir les gens, de le prendre, de le prendre en
compte et de le tisser autour d'un
thriller juridique, de divertir avant tout
le lecteur, mais aussi de lui
donner à réfléchir